TED-Ed team here.
As you know, we usually post
animated educator lessons,
but today we wanted to try something a little different,
and we need your help to figure out next steps.
We've recently learned that a large number
of students that use TED-Ed
want to know more about career options,
and that they and the teachers and guidance counselors
that work with them need better tools
to make that happen.
We've been busy trying to design
an interactive series to meet those needs,
and today we want to share three videos
that demo how the series could work.
Each video features four people
with four different careers
reading questions submitted by students.
The answers to those questions
and follow-up questions can be explored
choose-your-own-adventure style through annotations.
For the purposes of the demo,
we sourced a few questions from students
and recruited a few TED speakers
and other professionals to answer the questions,
but those two things were done independently
of one another.
The idea for the actual series
is that the next set of videos
would only feature questions and people
suggested and voted up by you, the viewers.
So, if you tell us that the next video
should undoubtedly feature an arachnologist,
an album art creator,
a particle physicist,
and an engineer,
all giving away their trade secrets for your benefit,
we'll try our best to make that happen.
We think this could be a pretty fun series,
and we look forward to your feedback.
Enjoy the demo!
Now for the story of you,
the TED-Ed community,
your questions about potential careers,
and the TED speakers and working professionals
that you nominate to answer those questions.
It's an interactive show.
Welcome to "Click Your Fortune".
"I'm Sandra Aamodt.
I'm a science writer and a neuroscientist.
I've written two books about the brain
for popular audiences,
and I edited a scientific journal."
"My name is Alessandro Centrone.
I work for Steelcase, the leading company
in office furniture manufacturing.
I have a responsibility for sales and distribution."
"My name is Adital Ela.
I call myself a sustainability designer,
and I try to explore how product design
can support social and environmental progress."
"John Werner.
Eighteen years ago, I started a network of schools
called Citizen Schools.
I lead TEDxBeaconStreet in Boston.
I'm also a research scientist at the MIT Media Lab."
Each professional will now draw one of your questions
from the fortune cookie jar.
You can choose your own path from there.
You can also click this fortune cookie
at any time to suggest questions,
TED speakers,
other professionals,
and other professions
to be featured in future videos.
Let's see what fortunes await
this batch of volunteers.
"What was a moment in time that I felt most inspired?"
"If you were to give a TED Talk,
or if you already have,
what ideas would you present?"
"What do you look for in an applicant's CV?"
"Okay, what ideas are you passionate about?"
You may now click any fortune
to see the question
and a handful of follow-up questions
explored by each speaker.
On the next "Click Your Fortune,"
you could you see the professional
you've always looked up to
answering questions you've always had
about the career you've always been curious about.
Click the fortune cookie to visit the TED-Ed community
and to suggest or vote up ideas for future videos.